I don't think that's true IIIi think the
Supreme Court has a lot of independent
authority would just take this term you
know it may be that the City Council of
Chicago of New York of la wants to ban
handguns in their city well as of this
year too bad Supreme Court says you
can't do it you know that that is real
power and when one of my favorite quotes
about the Supreme Court comes from
Robert Jackson who said we are not
Justice Robert Jackson who said we are
not final because we are infallible we
are infallible because we are final
somebody has to have the last word and
in our country to Supreme Court
i don't think i have a judicial
philosophy to speak of i I think I I I
guess you know in my book in in my
analysis I am somewhat cynical realistic
whatever you want to call it about the
political nature of judging when it
comes to the Constitution when you are
addressing questions like does the
Constitution protect a woman's right to
choose abortion does the Constitution
allow a university to consider race and
admissions I don't think those questions
have right or wrong answers when it
comes to interpreting the Constitution I
think there are reasonable views on both
sides as a legal matter what I think is
that their political that that it
depends what you think in terms of your
political philosophy I think political
philosophy means more than legal
competence or expertise in deciding the
big constitutional issue
mine's um well I mean I think there are
I think there are terrific thinkers
about the court I like reading Cass
Sunstein I like reading Larry tribe I
like reading Richard Posner I like
reading ronald dworkin but you know this
is not a moment where there are a lot of
judges out there who are legal
philosophers in the way that there have
been in the past there are people with
distinctive philosophies that they apply
in interesting and important ways but I
I don't think there are a lot of
geniuses in the way that there were
there were when there was homes and
learn at hand
you